- Hey, Alex, I heard you
have a question for me.
So, on his channel
- Yeah?
- He's applying science to ordinary foods
in ways that he's trying to improve it.
- Hey, Neil, what's up?
My name is Alex, I'm a YouTuber
and I make videos about food,
but from the DIY and
science point of view.
So my last video was about pan seasoning.
You know, the most common
and historical method
to season a pan is to burn fat inside it,
you create a dry, hard and
kind of non-stick surface.
So, allegedly, oil polymerization
is responsible for that.
Now, I am wondering, why does
that coating stick
to the material, the metal, in my case,
carbon steel or even cast iron.
And I'm also wondering, how could we make
that bond stronger?
Also, I know my question
is chemistry related
and that you are an astrophysicist,
so just imagine that
you're seasoning in space.
Thank you.
(laughter)
- That's pretty funny, seasoning in space.
- Just the way he speaks,
I want him to be my chef.
- Without a doubt.
- The food will be better
no matter what he's making.
- Exactly.
- He's making corn flakes, it's
gonna be French corn flakes.
- Absolutely, he can't cook
at all, it's just like,
he just tells you it's
good and you're like,
"This is delicious!"
"By ze way, you like dis."
"Mmm, oh my god."
- The accent makes it all better.
- Exactly, "I have seasoned
this with my words."
(laughter)
- Sorry, that's the American
mentality manifested there.
So, first of all, the oil that makes
the surface of the pan
non-stick, which, by the way,
is the secret of well-seasoned woks, okay?
A good iron wok has oil
that has been on there multiple times.
So, the oil is now the surface of the pan
and it's smooth, because the pan itself,
the metallic surface is structured, okay.
So, you put in oil and oil will fill all
the nooks and crannies
and make a smooth surface
and then you burn it there, okay.
So, then it just solidifies
that part that got burned.
Polymerization is what he's talking about.
My point is, beyond that,
it's stuck because it's
burned onto the pan.
You can remove it with a Brillo pad
or with heavy soap, you can remove it.
It's not permanently
affixed the way Teflon
is sort of permanently
attached, basically.
You know, you can take a
belt sander and remove it,
but otherwise, the Teflon is on.
So, it's not permanently attached.
It's there and you have to be careful
to not remove it when
it's time to wash it.
So, no, it's not permanently attached.
Why it's non-stick,
that's a really, really
smooth surface at that point
and not all smooth surfaces are non-stick,
so I don't have a good answer for that.
- So, I'll plead ignorance on this,
but what I did see
recently is the frontier
of non-stick surfaces, they're putting it
on the inside of a ketchup bottle.
- That makes sense.
- So you tip the - and it just slides out.
- It just slides out.
- You tip that mayonnaise bottle
the mayonnaise just slides out.
- Okay, that sounds nasty.
- That sounds wrong.
(laughter)
- You don't want mayonnaise coming to you.
- I don't want mayonnaise sliding my way.
No, I don't want any
mayonnaise sliding my way.
- You wanna go in and get the mayonnaise.
- Yes, exactly.
- You don't want the mayonnaise
chasing you down the street.
- I wanna manually mine my own mayonnaise.
(laughter)
- So the frontier of non-stick surfaces
when introduced to food means
there's much less food waste,
when trying to get the last of
the peanut butter in the jar,
the last of the mayonnaise,
the last of everything else.
At home, we have a whole set of tools,
what do you call them?
- Little spatulas.
- Spatulas, the little rubber -
- Yeah, I use them, too.
I get every little drop.
- They're basically squeegees.
- That's what they are.
Yep, get it all.
And I cut it open, too.
- You know nature's first squeegee?
- What?
- The tongue.
- There you go.
- Right?
That's what I do, I try not to do it
at a restaurant, but at
home, I'm licking the plate.
If the sauce was good,
I'm licking the plate.
- My Sister told me that that's in France
supposedly the highest
compliment you can pay a chef.
Is if you take the plate and you, I mean
you don't really ah-ah-ah.
But it's basically
- Tactfully.
- It's tactfully, one time and just like
that's compliments to the chef.
That's how good it was.
- That's like in some other parts,
if you burp, that's a good thing.
- Exactly right, and that's
my Uncle Jim's house.
(laughter)
If you burp, it's compliments to the chef.
- You don't have an Uncle Jim.
- And by the way, this was great beer.
- So, sorry, I only got
to half your answer there,
but that's the best that I can do
as an astrophysicist, not,
it's not so much chemist,
but material scientist.
They're the ones who
think about the surfaces
of solid objects and how they interact.
So, you know what he does?
He brings methods and
tools of science to food.
Now, he's not the first to do that,
but he does it in a very
fun and interesting way.
You see all his failures and you look
at the process, you look at the thoughts
that went into it, so I
just think that's great.
Because the kitchen is
the first and last bastion
of science in the households.
- Nice.
- You've got the chemistry of the food,
you add together the physics of the heat
and the thing, it's got the biology
'cause your cooking something
that was once alive.
- That's right, no matter
if it was a plant or not.
- Correct.
- Which is why, when I cut my carrots,
I hear 'em go, "Aaaaahhh!"
- Really, you cut your carrots...
My celery does that, they
must be from the same garden.
(upbeat music)